I realized that I got the date wrong
today it's actually the 21st but that's
all right it's close enough all right so
what is web assembly who has not heard
of web assembly in this room before
nobody has not heard of it awesome um I
will just briefly State what I think it
is I it's a portable low-level bite code
so that means that you compile programs
to it it's not something that you write
by hand although I've rotten written a
lot of it by hand
it runs on a software virtual machine
there is no Hardware out there that runs
web assembly natively but maybe soon uh
various research projects in the work in
the works but this is typically a thing
that you run through a software layer
which is good it was originally uh
launched for the web that was back in
2017 when it first became uh available
in browsers and now it's being used in
many domains so many different domains
that I won't list them
all this is my quote I had to come up
with a vision for this to to kind of
frame this talk who here has heard of
Unicode before okay everybody uses
Unicode it's the one standard for text
that we have before Unicode there were
so many different standards it was
terrible like now there's actually one
Unico is not perfect Unicode is the
union of all the things maybe that's not
quite what we want for web assembly but
I'm going in this general direction
thinking maybe web assembly will be the
binary format for all compiled code in
the future so it will not be perfect but
it'll be the the final standard where we
can move beyond having machine code at
the bottom of software so just a little
bit of my background so at the very when
I first started programming I thought I
want to design my own programming
language that was the first thing that I
wanted to do and ever since then I've
kind of been working at that from
different angles um when I learned Java
in 98 I immediately wanted to figure out
how does this Java thing work and that's
how I got into Java virtual machines so
when I started uh college that was 98 uh
I almost almost immediately thereafter I
started working on jvms there was a
project at at Purdue called open VM and
that was an idea to implement Java
inside of java itself and that was
actually got me really interested in
both languages and how they work inside
I worked at Sun uh both as an intern and
later as an employee after grad school I
worked a little bit with hotspot I
didn't I didn't do a whole lot with
hotspot um but then when I was in grad
school I did actually get a chance to
design my own programming language and I
still work on it and in fact wizard
which I'm going to talk about today is
written in Virgil so Virgil is a
language that's actually 20 years old um
I wrote an AVR emulator that's also kind
of like a little VM too and there's some
ideas from aora uh that I'm going to use
in this talk
too but after I graduated school I went
to work at Sun and I worked on this
thing called Maxine again a Java and
Java VM it turns out that Java is not
the best language for writing VMS and I
I think Virgil is a better language for
writing VMS which is why I'm using it
for for Wizard these
days after I worked at Sun I worked at
Google I worked on V8 for seven years I
primarily worked on the optimizing jit
compiler so I am not responsible for
JavaScript language design issues I
mostly don't even know anything about
JavaScript mostly only wrote JavaScript
in order to write web assembly tests uh
but I did try to make it fast and
turbofan the optimizing jit in V8 is
also the thing that makes web assembly
fast too so they're like kind of unified
at least at the backend architecture uh
and since that time so I I worked on the
web assembly VM uh pretty much from the
beginning and now I decided actually I
want to do research again I want to work
on what is what does it look like 20
years out what do VMS look like
architecture-- wise 20 years out and so
that's what wizard is about and that's
pretty much the most relevant part here
is this part here why do we build
research VMS so it turns out that
students don't know
anything and we have to to teach them
and we need artifacts to teach them so
we want them to become virtual machine
experts and they can get there and so
they need an need to have a vehicle to
do that and it needs to be simpler than
V8 V8 is 900,000 lines of code it's
written in C++ it's very intricate
that's not going to be something that a
student can be thrown in the deep end
and they they're going to be able to do
that they need something simpler and
also when we were talking about virtual
machines we need to pretend like we
actually know the the good things about
VMS and the bad things so we to compare
and contrast them so when you have a
research vehicle you can look at the
simple sort of textbook implementation
and you can look at a production
implementation and you can compare and
contrast them and we can pretend like
this is engineering as opposed to just
making stuff
up so when we do research we're talking
about what do what do VMS look like VMS
are under stress from various different
language features and various different
forces so there's going to be new
techniques that we want to employ to
make them better and faster so you want
a research vehicle to do that you want
to have something that's flexible we
also maybe want to look at programs and
how they behave in particular benchmarks
so that means dynamically analyzing them
it's nice to have an artifact that can
not only run a program but also can tell
you something interesting about the
execution you can get some insight into
the
execution and of course developing new
languages too languages need to have an
implementation it's better if you have a
vehicle that helps give you some
feedback about whether the
implementation is correct cor or not
again V8 is very fast but it doesn't
really like it when your programs have
bugs it likes to just crash your program
and tell you that your program's bad
that's not good feedback for a language
designer because you're going to have
crashing programs a lot you actually
want to see some insight and be able to
debug your compiler and of course web
assembly is evolving too so if we add
extensions are we going to do that in
production VMS or are we going to do
that in research uh
vehicles and of course a research engine
can help steer language Evolution too
not only of web assembly but also of
languages the easier it is to experiment
with a feature either in terms of a wasm
feature or a source level feature the
easier it is to try out many different
ideas and know which is
good and the other thing is actually I
think this can work well in Synergy with
production VMS by taking pressure off
them to support this use case a research
VM is designed to be flexible you're
supposed to try out lots of new ideas
you can't really do that in a production
VM unless it's been designed for that
and a production VM can't really serve
two masters of being both flexible and
also being highly performant so this
actually should work together they
should work together so there's a good
example of this so anybody heard of Jes
rvm
before there's a there's a handful of
hands so J's rvm was a research system
it still exists uh their by line was it
provides a flexible open test bed to
prototype Virtual Machine Technologies
and experiment with a large variety of
design ult Alternatives this was a
highly successful research project it
originally started an IBM research and
then got picked up by Academia and their
idea was to implement a Java VM that
people particularly grad students could
do things with and that was born out in
that almost 200 Publications came out of
that in at least 36 phds so I don't know
if wizard is going to quite achieve that
level of Fame in the research Community
but that's kind of what I've got in the
back of my head we need a vehicle like
that for web assembly so what is Wizard
wizard is a research engine designed for
flexibility and experimentation that's
going to be the highest priority there's
already a little bit of research coming
out so I I published a paper last year
in oopsa about The Interpreter design
web assembly is typically compiled to
machine code and nobody thought it was
really even possible to interpret it
directly and that's what that paper is
about I'll only briefly touch on that
it's not really the point of this talk
this is more of an overview talk what is
in this talk is I'm going to talk about
instrumentation the hooks in the API
because getting that insight into the
dynamic execution of programs and the VM
itself is actually the important thing
I'm going to talk a little bit about the
Baseline compiler which is how wizard
competes with production VMS and being
fast what I'm not going to talk about
which are also cool things uh it
implements several of the extensions
that have been proposed for web assembly
so things like garbage collection
exception handling uh memory multi
memory and things like that um I am not
going to talk about exploring extensions
to uh support new languages on web
assembly although that's also an
interesting thing that I'm interested in
um and I'm also not going to imple I'm
not going to talk about the language
that it's implemented in although I
would love to I spent 20 years working
on Virtual I'd love to spend a whole
hour talking about it but I won't there
are Talks on YouTube there are papers
that you can pretend to read and also
not site if you're interested in
that okay so what are the priorities you
actually have to write these down I
think if you're starting a software
system and you don't know what the
requirements are and you don't know what
the priorities are you probably end up
with something that maybe isn't doesn't
meet the needs of what you started out
with these are the priorities I came up
with and this is the order that I came
up with number one at the top
observability we want to see what
happens at run time it's great to go
fast but we actually want to see what
happened because things crash things
have weird behaviors and this is a
research setting so we want to look at
all of that the other thing is is that
wizard hopefully will be used by
students
it should be approachable it should be
code that's not terrifying like C++ is
in my
opinion uh so it should be something
where you can read the code you can read
documentation you can read the design
and you can get into it quite easily
I'll talk about later about how we
measure that I have no idea how to
measure that um we'll see it needs to be
competitive in terms of performance it
doesn't have to be top tier performance
so it's not going to be as fast as a
production engine like V8 but it has to
be close enough so that if you have a
research result in the research engine
you can at least see how it might
transfer so you can kind of eyeball
things you have to be in the same
ballpark and then last but not least it
needs to be flexible and extensible
because that's what students are going
to going to work on they're going to try
something out and so they want to be
able to do that inside of wizard okay
contrast with that with V8 uh there's
only one priority I maybe maybe not
quite true but really ultimate
performance that is the top priority and
in making this talk I really racked my
brain to think about what are the other
priorities for V8 and for an engineering
team and I they're way down there but
it's that V8 is a complicated system
there's uh you know dozens of people
working on it it has to support new
language features and its internal
complexity is to the point where it is
really Beyond human comprehension at
least Beyond a single person's
comprehension and so it's really
designed all those other things are are
kind of filtering up to that the
engineer ing team really can support it
and evolve it for the future and these
other things observability they're kind
of under there maybe uh but they're
really uh serving that goal of of M
making it a a system that's maintainable
and
sustainable so what does observability
mean so in particular web assembly being
a code format it goes into this software
virtual machine and so those things that
happen when you take a the format and
and turn it into an internal
representation so parsing the code
decoding the code and actually
validating the type system of web
assembly those are all things that you
may actually want to make observable in
particular if you're a language designer
you've written a compiler and you're
generating web assembly which is a
binary format and you will probably get
it wrong and so you want the engine to
tell you exactly what went wrong and
where so the observability basically
boils down to having nice tracing modes
having nice output and telling you if
you have a type error kind of making a
nice error message so you can figure out
what's wrong with your compiler again
this is more targeted towards people who
are potentially generating web assembly
code that's broken and so those good
error messages really really matter and
then the other parts of observability
are of course the execution of the
program what happens when you execute
the program the engine itself is doing
things like it's doing those activities
like loading code and and parsing and
validating the code but it also may be
compiling functions it may be allocating
memories and things like that you may
want to analyze the the engine's
performance and maybe just generally get
a picture of what's going on that's also
instructive to understand what the
engine is doing with your code when you
give it to it because you potentially
being a language implementer may be
optimizing your compiler so you want to
get an idea of what's going on you can't
optimize something you can't see or
measure and then of course if you're
maybe not a language implementer or
designer you may be studying benchmarks
or programs or other things you want to
see what those programs do are they
running in a hot Loop are they
allocating a lot of memory is it jumping
between lots of different functions
what's going on you know if you run a
benchmark and you get a number like it's
three seconds long it's not a whole lot
of information you instead want to see
into that execution what's there and
then of course it turns out that
programs have bugs and I have tried many
years to stop doing that but it keeps
happening so I have made mistakes in
writing the engine and I have found that
for my own uh velocity being able to
debug the code that I wrote in the
engine and by extension students who may
add extensions to the engine will also
have to debug their code so we want to
be able to debug the engine itself but
also debug user programs too because
again compiler writers are going to
generate code that may be wrong maybe it
gets through the validator maybe it
doesn't but it's going to crash so we
want to get some insight there so that's
all part of this observability goal okay
so how does this actually break down so
we're going to do some Dynamic analysis
so don't be afraid of those words it
just means looking at programs
running the insights that I came away uh
with from doing a bit of exploration
into the kinds of things that you want
to look at is that actually most dynamic
program analyses actually are tied to
very specific locations in a program so
the API that you come up with actually
makes sense to think of how are we going
to add instrumentation to a program it's
probably going to be tied to locations
in the program sometimes it's tied to
specific data in a program but usually
we can also get to that by instrumenting
particular locations but other than that
it's typically very sparse in time so
you know you might have a program and it
executes three billion instructions
clearly you're not going to just dump
out a log of three billion instructions
and sort do that with GP or something
like that so it's actually very sparse
so you want to have instrumentation
that's targeted to very specific things
that a program might do but other than
that the commonality start to break down
you really have lots of different things
that you might want to look at when a
program is executing different events
you might want to look at different ways
of analyzing the events so ultimately is
crying out for some kind of
programmability in terms of um the
instrumentation and observability so
just examples to kind of paint the
picture here what if I want to see the
parts of the program that have been
executed versus not that's called code
coverage that's a clear example of
something where you want to add some
instrumentation to the program to record
that
maybe I'm interested in which branches
in their program are very unpredictable
maybe I'm working on Research that's a
branch predictor or something like that
so profiling the branches or maybe a
compiler optimization toward targeted
towards branches or maybe I'm interested
in the memory system or maybe I'm
interested in understanding a bit more
about the program and I want to see what
functions call what so construct a
dynamic call
graph if you want to build a debugger
you want break points right you want to
stop at a particular location in the
program and then then look at the
program state or maybe even better
actually stop when a particular memory
location is accessed that's one of the
great things about a debugger is that
where's this thing getting overwritten
so you want watch points and also
tracing to all those things and then
going beyond that you know you can think
of more advanced use cases like maybe I
want to fuzz a program or inject a fault
and study things at that level so
there's kind of climbing a hierarchy
here so this all boils down to one thing
in Wizard it's callbacks this is not
really like rocket science it's just
call
backs so I give you an idea so I
mentioned that wizard has an interpreter
for web assembly so this is a block of
web assembly code over here obviously
this is text but it's going to work on
the binary format but if we think about
this little program here this web
assembly program there's maybe some
point that's interesting to us as a as
an analyzer of this uh program and what
we really want is to add some logic
which is just a call back that happens
whenever this point is exec
executed and whatever we want to see
about the program we can package that up
behind an interface called the frame
accessor and the frame accessor
basically gives this user call back a
view of the state of the executing WM
program whether that's the actual memory
that the program is using uh the
execution stack including all the
functions that are on the execution
stack and all the values that the
program is manipulating having this one
pinch point in the API means that the
engine knows every time that this
callback is accessing the program State
and so the engine is actually going to
be able to optimize against that
interface okay so there's this there's a
couple of different ways of doing that
so one way is that you can add a probe
to The Interpreter Loop itself so you
get a call back for every single bite
code that's executed this is like the
shotgun approach to doing program
analysis it's not super sparse and it's
not going to be super efficient but
wizard has a way to do that for like
quick and dirty analysis is like tracing
every bite code and it's implemented
efficiently and so there's a trick that
I use here that I'll explain um so this
is The Interpreter State the red things
are The Interpreter state so there's a
IP which is the instruction pointer
where The Interpreter keeps track of the
current executing B code so wherever we
are in the actual machine uh sorry the
web web assembly code uh there's a
pointer to the end of the code too but
also there is some table that tells The
Interpreter what to do for every kind of
by code and that's called a dispatch
table and so the idea here is that
dispatch table is not a fixed thing but
instead there's a register that points
to that dispatch table which normally
points to a dispatch table the blue one
that points to the actual machine code
for what to do for every single
different kind of op code and the idea
is that if you have a global probe where
you want a call back for every single
bite code we just swap the register and
the register now points to a different
table and that table every entry in that
table actually just goes to another
instrumented version that calls the user
call back and the idea being that when
you switch on this instrumentation we
only have to switch one register if we
want to switch it off we can switch the
register back and because there's no
overhead for the normal path we're
always just using this dispatch table
which is the normal one if things aren't
turned on it means that we don't need to
have a debugging mode for interpreter
for our for our VM you don't need to
build wizard in a special way to get
this it's always there
and it imposes no overhead on the quote
unquote production performance so this
is a key thing which is a good
ergonomics thing is that those that
instrumentation capability is always
there with no
overhead okay obviously doing a call
back for every bik code it sounds lame
it's not going to be fast it isn't fast
even with that trick it's not fast
that's probably not what you want to do
and in particular again usually a
program there are specific points of
interest where you want to get some
insight so in this one
yeah ah so you mean bite code in terms
of bite code class or bite code
themselves yet so this one would be
literally every single bite code
regardless of its op code
class but I do have a trick that will do
it per op code class too and if you
think about it it's like if you just
modify this sorry if you just modify the
dispatch table entry for a particular
class of op code yeah but no this is
every dynamically executed by code
excellent question thank you okay so
local probes are the idea that yes it's
sparse in space and time there are only
specific places in the program that we
want to instrument and so we know them
at some point so let's call in
particular and the idea is that we can
make The Interpreter also support this
by making a copy of the code and
overriding that bite code so I chose
this very ugly pink color on on purpose
so The Interpreter is going to run
through and it's executing bik codes
it's going through that dispatch table
when it hits this probe op code there's
going to be an entry oh this means this
this instruction itself has been
instrumented and we can keep a copy of
the original code so that we only have
to make one modification and the idea is
that when The Interpreter hits this op
code then it calls the user call back
and since we've got a copy of the
original code and we've only modified
the thing at the particular offset we
don't actually have to insert any
particular we don't have to insert bite
code we actually know where we were and
knowing where we were to tell the user
program we reached this place is
actually very useful so it turns out
that if you wanted to implement this by
B code rewriting and inserting code you
have to constantly map back to what was
the original offset and that's a pain
and there's bugs it's just like way
simpler to do it this way and it's
actually more efficient too so after
we've called the user call back we
actually want to execute the code that
was there and and since we've got the
original code we can just load the
original bite from there and since we
know the offset that's actually very
efficient so there's no searching here
there's no like inserting bite codes and
not not knowing where the offsets are
and then we'll just execute the original
code and the great thing about that too
is that we can remove them so not only
can we insert probes but we can remove
them by just taking the bite from the
original code and writing it back and so
now The Interpreter won't trip over the
probe B code and we go back to full
speed Okay so I'm going to run through
an example of how we build a more
complex analysis so this is the
mechanism at the bottom so the global
probe and the local probe are the
mechanisms that wizard gives you to
write the more complicated analyses so
let's talk about code coverage we're
going to use probes here and the key
thing that we just went through is that
you can insert and you can also remove
probes so for code crage what we're
going to do is we could do it by
instruction so we could pick every
single instruction or we could do it by
basic block we'll just pick basic blocks
for this example so again we're going to
make a copy of the code so we're going
to insert probes at the beginning of
every basic block which is
here and then we're going to keep some
State on the side which is which of the
basic blocks have we actually
executed and by inserting probes there's
going to be all those instructions are
overwritten and what's going to happen
is that when we actually when The
Interpreter actually executes that code
it's going to call the user call back
and that user call back again is any
logic that we wrote and so this logic in
particular just updates the state for B1
so we're going just going to overwrite
that and record that that block was
executed but the key thing is this is
code coverage we only need to do that
once so we can remove that probe so once
that probe is removed it will never
execute again it will have never it will
not have overhead the next time and so
as the program executes it's going to
fire the probes as it hits them newly
and update the state and So eventually
we're going to get to to a point where
all the blocks in the program that have
been executed have removed their
instrumentation and they've also
recorded that they have been
executed and so that means that the hot
part of the program is eventually going
to get compiled by a jit compiler for
example with no overhead at all so we
sort of ASM totically approached the
performance that you would have by the
things removing the instrumentation uh
themselves as they go along most systems
you can't actually remove the the
instrumentation once it's been inserted
this is one of the reasons why you might
want to support
that okay so there's lots of things that
you can start building with this and so
I had students uh hack on Wizard which
is part of the reason that I think that
wizard is hackable is that students were
able to do this and Implement lots of
different things this required no
additional changes to the VM it's just a
thing that's built with probes so in
particular there's this thing and also
they spend a lot of time making those
nice terminal colors I'm very proud of
that so the loop monitor in particular
this one is basically you just insert a
counter at the beginning of every Loop
in web assembly that's a loop bite code
so you can find them very easily you
don't even have to do any control flow
analysis you just run through find all
the loops in the in the program you
insert a probe on them which is a
counter and then actually most of the
logic is making the nice pretty colors
at the end so this really only like a
dozen lines of code to insert the the uh
the probes themselves it's similar for
branch profiling so Branch profiling is
a little bit more complicated because
you want to record which direction every
Branch went true or false and also for
switches like which of the switch cases
you went to and so this one actually not
only does it have a a probe that fires
at a particular location that probe
actually loads the top of the wasm stack
and figures out which way the branch
would go and so it turns out to be
Implement turns out to be much easier to
implement it that way as opposed to
implementing the targets of branches and
trying to figure out where you came from
and then again
uh nice print out at the end but
ultimately the logic is very simple
engine doesn't know anything about it
it's just a probe that fires at a
location and it can give it the top of
the stack code coverage we saw
instruction tracing so wizard has lots
of different modes where you can ask it
please just tell me like what's
executing either this function or
whatever there's nothing custom in the
VM for that it's all just implemented
with
probes um you can also do profiling too
of the calls and so that that one is
just implemented with probes at the
beginning a function that record what
the time is and then output a nice
pretty flame graph or other um display
of that um the hotness monitor I love
the hotness monitor it's hot it just
counts all the instructions in the
program and then it gives you this nice
display about what is hot what is the
hottest part of the program how much of
the code actually constitutes for
example the top 90% of executed
instructions and so the instrumentation
part of that's really simple
and so there's kind of a theme is the
instrumentation part is actually fairly
trivial and then it's all about
presentation uh there's also a debugger
too the debugger uses probes to do uh
break points and also watch points as
well and it allows you to for example
see the stack you can see the locals you
can even change the locals so you can do
like fixing continue it is a bite code
level debugger so it's not super awesome
so you are debugging WM bite code but if
again if you're a language designer and
you're trying to bug the code that your
compiler uh has emitted you might
actually want to step through it and so
that's what that gives
you it turns out that these probe
mechanism they're very it's very low
level we're talking about B code things
we're looking at the bite code State
we're looking at this you know
instructions we're not looking at source
level uh stuff we might actually want to
look at higher level things and I I
think that what that means is that we're
building a hierarchy of instrumentation
capabilities so we can build everything
from Global bite code probes those are
the ones that execute every bite code
but obviously if we use local probes
they're more efficient because they only
execute when that particular uh
instruction is executed but they also
tell the engine the intent which is I
only care about this instruction as
opposed to caring about lots of things
and so the engine can optimize against
the
intent and so what we started to to
build is a a higher level API that has
the kitchen sink of all the things that
is implemented in of the low lower level
things so in particular like you didn't
see anything for memory instrumentation
here that can be built with probes you
didn't see anything for function entry
and exit that can be built with probes
it turns out that's tricky and I'm going
to show you in just a minute uh but
basically we're building up libraries to
make this much better so I'll give you
an idea why that doesn't really work to
just function entry and exit is actually
really tricky in particular uh you think
well I'll just insert a probe at the
beginning of a function and and at the
end of a function but actually a
function it's like a nasty special case
waiting for you it could start with a
loop and so if you your probe is going
to fire every time around this Loop and
if you just put it at the end well maybe
there's earlier turns in the middle so
you don't want every user who's
interested in just function entry and
exit they'll have to go and handle those
special cases so instead what you do is
you have a call stack emulation so
implemented in terms of probes there's a
nice library that will put a probe at
the beginning it will be able to tell
the difference between the the loop
coming back around and being entered
from the F the first time and it will
also instrument the returns and it will
also instrument any like unwinds that
you have and then the nice Library calls
your user call back so you don't
actually even have to see probes so
we're kind of getting into the phase
where we're figuring out what's in the
nice nice
Library okay observability is great so
this picture is the overhead of the
branch monitor so this is execution time
is up and this is relative execution
time so this is a bunch of different
benchmarks and so you want to be close
to 1.0 that means no overhead okay and
this is actually comparing two different
things so bite code rewriting would be
what you do if you do not have any
support in the engine for doing
instrumentation you just rewrite the
program to insert instructions and
because there's more instructions it's
going to be uh more overhead on the
program it turns out it's about a 2X
overhead if you want to insert the kind
of instructions that you need to record
branches it's also very tedious it's not
super fun uh if you use local probes and
you use Wizards facilities it's kind of
in the noise it's like on the order of
10 to 20%
overhead which is great so not only is
it a lot more uh ergonomic and easy to
use it's Al also lower
overhead but this is an interpreter
right so 15% slower than an
interpreter that's not that's not great
I mean interpreters are a lot slower
than compiled code in fact so wizard
does have a baseline compiler it is you
get like a 20x Improvement in
performance so what does it mean in
terms of relative overhead 15% in The
Interpreter versus
20x that's not a research result that
you can publish so I wouldn't want to
write a paper and then have a reviewer
tell you tell me oh that's great that
you made The Interpreter only 15% slower
what about the compiled code so you
can't really do that so now we actually
have to get into regime where when we're
talking about overheads or we're talking
about mechanisms we have to have a
system which has at leasts competitive
performance and so that means it's jit
time I love writing jit compilers it's
like my seventh jit compiler
okay so uh I buil a baseline jit for
Wizard that is basically a single pass
compiler that is designed to be really
simple and easy to understand and
hackable for students I did even have
stud students hack it but also gives you
good code and also supports this
instrumentation and so the fact that it
supports this instrumentation means that
you don't see it as a user of the VM or
as a person who's hacking on the VM you
can write all of your instrumentation
and the jit compiler will just work
around it and one of the key things here
that makes that work is the jit compiler
uses the same stack frame layout as The
Interpreter so particular it's this
picture which should be obvious
that how awesome it
is so at the bottom here the blue that's
the execution stack so that's like the
native x86 execution stack and so that
grows to the left so it use points two
by RSP the key idea is that those stack
frames there they're the same size
between The Interpreter and the jit
compiled code that means that we can
flip between jit code and The
Interpreter really
easily so the orange-ish thing I
actually maybe kind of peach I don't
even know where I came up with this
color color but that's the value stack
that's where the wm's D the WM programs
Dynamic values are stored if we also use
the same layout for that then it means
that it's effectively compatible between
The Interpreter and the jit compiler so
here we see a on the right right bottom
here we see a zoomed in picture of the
execution frames the things an
interpreter frame has are like a pointer
into the code a pointer to the function
a pointer to the instance you know a
pointer to where you are on the value
stack and things like that and a jit
frame has almost all the same things
except it doesn't have like an
instruction pointer it may or may not
actually move the stack pointer as it's
going along but to flip between the two
you just have to go if you're going from
jit code to The Interpreter you just
have to come up with the things that
aren't in the actual aren't being
maintained by the jit code and vice
versa it's actually pretty easy you just
need to know where to go in the machine
code so flipping back and forth between
the two of them means that we can do
observability so around instrumentation
if we decide okay there's a probe or
we've inserted a probe in the code now
oh that function is jit compiled it's
very easy to go back to The Interpreter
and of course lots of systems do that in
fact va va does that it's the most
complicated thing in a VM is getting
that right and so wizard is designed so
that that's that mechanism is so simple
it's like impossible to screw that it's
not impossible but it is very hard to
screw it up and it's easy to understand
how it works so you can throw a student
at and be like fix this thing in the osr
mechanism and they can do it uh that's
not possible with V8 V8 is actually very
intricate
there so we can also go both directions
right we can go from The Interpreter to
the jit that happens if we've got a hot
Loop so wizard is now gotten to the
point where it's like other engines it
will dynamically adapt to your program's
execution it will start off in The
Interpreter and then it will warm up to
the jit compiler that's because we want
to have faster startup and so that's
really easy to do now with this setup of
the stack frame
layouts but we also go the other
direction so a lot of VMS go the other
Direction when they make optimizations
that are speculative wizard doesn't do
speculative optimizations it only goes
back to The Interpreter if you change
instrumentation and so we'll do that
transparently so the picture is
basically like this a baseline compiler
for web assembly is designed for fast
compile speed as opposed to highest code
quality and it basically will make one
pass over the
code it will use an abstract interpreter
meaning that it effectively models
what's on the web assembly's value stack
as it's generating code and it will
generate code for one instruction at a
time for compiler people that sounds
kind of lame you know like at one
instruction at a time the code's going
to be really bad as it turns out that
web assembly because it's a stack
machine and because the control flow is
structured even doing Cod gen one
instruction at a time you get pretty
good code because all the instructions
that manipulate the stack and manipulate
local variables those mostly manipulate
the abstract State and you can
registrate allocate as you go along so
both V8 and spider monkey all the web
engines they have Baseline compilers for
web assembly Wizards is very similar um
there I could go into some details but
it's really not that important but the
idea is that you get code out very
quickly you don't have to backtrack and
supporting Pro is actually really easy
because again the program uh sorry the
instrumentation has given its intent by
saying I am interested in this part of
the code which is the ugly purple probe
thing and when the compiler gets there
it's really easy is to just insert a
call to the
runtime for some probes uh for example
like maybe you just want to count how
many times this particular instructions
executed the jit also understands that
some kind of probes are special and it
will generate special machine code so
two instructions in this case it looks
like one was actually two instructions
uh and that's like very low overhead so
you can use counter probes and they will
become super efficient when they get you
compiled okay so what is that all mean
in this in the grander scheme of things
so this is a this is a two-dimensional
trade-off in performance so on the
x-axis notice the x-axis is log
logarithmic that's the amount of time it
takes to get going to execute so that's
a processing time per code bite so it's
normalized per bite of web assembly code
and it turns out they're grouped very
interestingly and the scatter plot is
going to be and the different colors are
those are different execution tiers for
WM so that's interpreters Baseline
compilers optimizing compilers and
interpreters that rewrite the
code and the the y axis here the
vertical axis that's execution time
that's normalized to running on V8 so
high higher is worse lower is better and
you can see there's like very clear
groupings between execution strategies
for uh web assembly code all the
optimizing compilers they take
effectively eons to compile a function
because they build an IR and they do
optimizations and they do register
allocation they're way over there to the
right but they're down at the bottom
because they generate the best code and
in fact if you were to zoom in there
basically all the optimizing compilers
are about the same speed as V8 turbofan
and then for the Baseline compilers they
generate code much faster because they
are the single pass design as I showed
but they don't generate quite as good as
code so they kind of a little bit higher
up those are all the blue ones there and
then rewriting interpreters they
actually walk over the code to generate
another IR to interpret but they're
interpreting that ir and so they're much
lower uh wizard gen wizard interprets
the bytes directly so it doesn't have to
rewrite anything that's why it's so much
farther to the left because the overhead
of basically just validating the code
that's what that is
and so the idea here is that Wizards jit
fits right in there it's just like
pretty much all the other Baseline
compilers but you get the special power
of that it supports instrumentation just
like The
Interpreter so the summary is it's fast
I mean that's it should probably be
qualified it's not as fast as V8 it's as
fast as v8's Baseline compiler um it's a
little bit faster than some benchmarks
but these are really in the in the same
ballpark um I won't really go into value
tagging I probably shouldn't have put
that on the slide but one of the things
that uh makes it possible to interpret
and also compile and use the same frame
layout is the way values are represented
on uh Wizard's value stack but the key
thing is is that full instrumentation
capabilities which means that when you
use Wizard and you write probes and you
insert probes and even remove probes and
maybe insert more probes later it's all
completely transparent you you can think
of it like an interpreter and the jit
just kind of works in the background and
and makes your code faster
faster and deoptimization in Wizard's
case again it doesn't do any speculative
optimizations it will only deop to The
Interpreter if you change the
instrumentation so it's got predictable
performance okay so that's all about the
observability and also competitive per
performance to some extent what about
this approachability metric I honestly
don't really know how to measure this is
quite subjective but I can at least
measure the Simplicity in terms of lines
of code so in Wizard uh it takes about
18,000 lines of code to implement the
engine that includes all of The
Interpreter and Baseline compiler and
all of the validation everything it's
all 18,000 lines of code and I didn't
really do a lot to make it like you know
cramming things on one line I don't I
didn't do a whole lot of that just in
comparison V8 just the code to parse WM
and to type check it and to make an IR
for it that's about 57,000 lines of code
that's C++ code um there's like lots of
includes and stuff like that uh so it's
a little bit bigger than it could be but
that's actually significantly more
complicated and then when you start
adding execution tiers a baseline tier
for one architecture is 177,000 lines of
code and then the optimizing compiler in
V8 which I love and I spent many years
working on it's huge it's 290,000 lines
of code so I don't think a student is
going to be able to do anything in in V8
uh in the time frame of a particular of
a semester so I think in terms of
Simplicity wizard has an advantage there
how robust is the system so one of those
things is that I mentioned programs have
bugs people make mistakes so when the
thing crashes how do you know what do
you do and one of the great things about
wizard is that I spent two decades
designing Virgil so that you don't crash
as much it's a nice memory safe language
it's garbage collected um and so you
just avoid a lot of bugs and so that
means that actually that it should be a
lot more robust so you don't have the
kinds of things that that bite you uh in
another
system I didn't really talk about it
here but there's actually two
interpreters inside of WM uh sorry in in
inside of wizard there's the one that I
wrote in uh Assembly Language to be fast
but there's also one that's just Pure
virgal Source Code so that uses arrays
all the things are bounds checked and
stuff like that so you can write nice
source code and so you can really write
like 10 lines of code to add a bite code
to
that uh how self-explanatory is this
system I don't know how to measure that
um I think there's a lot less noise in
the virgal code that I wrote there um
the documentation is probably not as
good as it should be but that's
something that we can work
on okay just to give you an idea where
does all the lines of code go okay 14
lines of code this defines all the web
assembly values that you have in Wizard
so this is just a this is just a virgal
syntax for writing an algebraic data
type so values can be references they
can be I 31s they can be 32 and 64bit
integers and floating point and also
vectors too and they and they have a way
to print them out the same amount of
code that does the same thing in V8 is
241 lines because C++ doesn't have adts
so you have to write them by hand you
write a class and it has sub classes and
you have a union and you have a tagging
mechanism so just throwing a student at
V8 at V8 and saying Okay add a web
assembly value and they have to go
through that code and make it work and
then they have to go find compile errors
and other places where it's missing um
that's just a lot more work because it
just takes a lot more code and of course
like if you use another language like
rust for example or okel then you also
get this mechanism so just having nice
language mechanism means that we cut
down on
code all right and that's all I got I
think I got thank you man thank
[Applause]
you